[Music]
perhaps a staple of all world
mythologies
is the presence of extraordinary and
strange beasts
from the minotaur and cyclops of greek
myth to the many bizarre yokai of
japanese folklore
but what about the bible in this video
let's take a look at four unusual
creatures found in the old testament
and examine where academics believe
these strange beasts may have come from
unicorns okay this should be familiar
territory
horses with horns we all know what
unicorns look like
surprisingly they're actually mentioned
quite a few times in the bible
in the book of numbers it describes god
as being like a unicorn
god brought them out of egypt he hath as
it were the strength of a unicorn
another example is in the book of job
where god rhetorically asks
will the unicorn be willing to serve
thee or abide by thy crib
now if you've watched some of my other
videos you'll know that a great place to
start
is looking at the original language in
hebrew they're not called unicorns
instead they're simply called re-em
remember this word
m we'll come back to it in a second when
the greeks began translating the bible
they translated this hebrew word rem to
monokeros
which simply means one horn similarly
latin speakers translated the word as
unicornis
from which we get our word unicorn
speaking of greeks and romans
strangely unicorns do not feature in
their mythologies
instead they are featured in ancient
greco-roman natural encyclopedias
basically ancient textbooks on nature
this is all to say that people did not
think
unicorns were mythical beasts but
actually real-life creatures
as real as a cow lion or horse
why well it's a case of mistaken
identity
this one-horned creature is actually a
rhino
when early travelers went to faraway
lands they spoke of strange creatures
they saw on their way
one was called a unicorn for example
roman naturalist pliny the elder offers
his description of a unicorn as
a very fierce animal called the unicorn
which is the head of a stag
the feet of an elephant and the tail of
a ball while the rest of the body is
like that of a horse
scholars believe that pliny is offering
an imperfect description of a rhino
it is likely that he heard a second hand
or even third-hand description of one
and is recounting it in this book the
description of a rhino became distorted
with each telling
a bit like a game of telephone so
returning back to the bible and unicorns
we can see how the original description
of a rhino
may have been distorted when it first
got translated remember the hebrew word
for unicorn
re-em well it doesn't mean rhino but a
creature
rather similar the rem has now been
identified as an animal
the nearby acadians called the rimu
today we'd call it an aurochs
an ancient ancestor of modern day cattle
so when the bible talks about unicorns
and so on
it's actually referring to an ancient
type of bull
so now it's a case of a triple mistaken
identity
originally the bible described a bull
which was then
misinterpreted as a unicorn which itself
was a misinterpretation of a rhino
a bit convoluted but hey okay next beast
leviathan and behemoth these are perhaps
the most famous mythical creatures in
the whole bible
ones you may be familiar with the
behemoth and leviathan
appear in the book of job as part of a
wider speech
god offers an extensive description of
each creature
let's start with the behemoth it's a
gigantic land creature of immense
strength
here's the full description behold bear
moth
which i made as i made you he eats grass
like an ox
behold his strength in his loins and his
power in the muscles of his belly
he makes his tail stiff like a cedar his
sinews of his thighs are knit together
his bones are tubes of bronze his limbs
like bars of iron
he is the first of the works of god
let him who made him bring near his
sword
for the mountains yield food for him
where all the wild beasts play
under the lotus plants he lies in the
shelter of the reeds and in the marsh
for his shade the lotus trees cover him
the willows are the brooks around him
behold if the river is turbulent he is
not frightened
he is confident though jordan rushes
against his mouth
can one take him by his eyes or pierce
his nose with a snare
now just after this description comes
the leviathan
this creature is a giant sea monster
serpentine
scaly and very ferocious the description
is a bit longer than beer moths so i
won't read out in full
only some select verses so you get the
picture his back
is made of rows of shields shut up
closely as with a seal
one is so near the other so that no air
can come between them
out of his mouth go flaming torches
sparks of fire
leap forth out of his nostrils comes
forth smoke
as from a boiling pot and burning rushes
his breath kindles coals and a flame
comes forth from his mouth
can you fill his skin with harpoons or
head with fishing spears
lay your hands on him remember the
battle you will not do it again
so some scholars have tried the same
tactic applied with the unicorn
finding a real-life counterpart to match
these descriptions
let's start with a beer moth a large
land animal that eats grass like an ox
and is known for its incredible strength
but mostly just relaxes in shaded waters
if you guessed a hippo you'd be right
okay
how about a leviathan an aquatic reptile
that has tough scaly skin
and rows of sharp teeth did you think of
a crocodile
so potentially god is not describing two
mythical beasts
but simply two real-life animals just
with a bit of pizzazz
at one point in time this view was
really popular amongst scholars
but it's had its problems over the years
mostly with the leviathan
how do we account for the creature's
fiery breath or its serpentine
appearance
plus the leviathan lives in the depths
of the seas whereas crocodiles typically
live in fresh water
another popular theory hopes to offer a
better explanation
these are not descriptions of real
animals but instead really are
descriptions of mythical beasts with
great power
see the leviathan has a bit of a history
with this one in a bunch of myths across
the world
especially creation myths there's a
trope of gods doing battles with sea
monsters
just like leviathan the germans called
it the chaos camp
or primordial battle for example in the
babylonian creation myth
the enumera elish the chief god marduk
defeats the seabeast tiamat
and creates the land sea and sky with
her dismembered body
a very similar story comes from an
ancient canaanite myth in which the
seabeast lotan
is slayed by the chief god baal at the
start of creation
in fact the name lotan is generally
believed to be where we get the name
leviathan
in the first place the chaos camp
appears more than just the middle east
the north god thor battles with the
world serpent jormungander
the greek god zeus slays the serpentine
tiffon
the hindu deity indra defeats the
aquatic snake demon
vitra and even as far as japan we have
the shinto storm god
susanoo who slays the eight headed sea
serpent yamato no orochi
so out of this we get the idea of the
leviathan this primordial sea snake of
creation
but note that in the book of job god's
not doing battle with the leviathan
instead he's celebrating its majesty and
it all seems to invert the trope on its
head
oh and the counterpart biamoth sadly
it's not really well known where it
comes from
some say it's a giant mythical cow after
all
its name biermoth is related to the
hebrew word for cattle
behema with this they suspect that it
could be related to a giant bull
in the epic of gilgamesh that was sent
down from heaven to do battle with the
heroes
gilgamesh and enkidu who knows the
jury's out on this one
perhaps the beer moth is some sort of
other creature that only ever appears
here
in this part of the bible and nowhere
else
the nephilim final creatures for now the
nephilim
literally translating to the fallen ones
but often just called the giants i
touched on them in a video by the
origins of lucifer
but to summarize the nephilim are said
to be the offspring of a forbidden
procreation between angels and
humans this story is expounded on at
length in the apocalypse book of enoch
where they cause havoc and generally
just cause a bit of a mess
now that's an apocryphal account and not
in the mainstream bible canon
so if we limit it just to the bible
there isn't really much about them
in genesis they are said to be warriors
of renown
and in the book of numbers the
israelites described themselves
as being the size of grasshoppers in
comparison to them
the real debate is whether we take it
literally or if they're just being
emphatic
maybe these are just exaggerated
descriptions of real life warriors
well the book of enoch takes it
literally and even goes a step further
measuring the nephilim at a whopping
1.35 kilometers
that's 4500 feet tall but who knows
the book of enoch is just one of many
interpretations a clue
could be in the earliest translations of
the bible which follow the same pattern
and translate nephilim as gigantes which
by the way is where we get our word for
giants
so there you have it i find that reading
the text in their original language
really reveals a lot about ancient texts
like the bible
the new testament especially the book of
revelations has some really wacky
creatures
like dragons and creatures covered
entirely with eyes perhaps a topic for a
future video
either way i really hope you enjoyed
this video and if you're new here
subscribe a like and a comment also goes
a long way
it's great to see so much activity on
this channel and so many positive
responses to my content
i might wish to produce more videos and
mythology and biblical studies in the
future
but i'm open to any and all suggestions
who knows
next week's topic could be entirely
different and by the way this channel
has a discord
check the link in the description head
on there and join the discussion
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time goodbye